give you quick fun facts or to derail
the meeting but I have to once pull the
Lottery scratch-off ticket but we were
very disciplined there was somebody at
the register so I put it back like rung
up the person person because I want a
scratch off I went to the thing above
because I pulled that one he goes no no
I want that one I gave it to him
person scratch it off and won $5,000 no
and to this day it is still the weirdest
moment in my life I lost when I tell you
I lost my mind I ran out of the store so
the guy scratch it and loses his mind
won $5,000 I did react by comply mean my
reaction was the greatest like way over
the top of anything you ever seen for me
screaming like corrects like her like I
saw a ghost ran out of the store went
behind the store and cried
[Music]
chuckling for you
I think we'll do this fun it with this
group and this you know I think we need
to start making some of these meetings
look like this is this is a good time to
just kind of shoot the [ __ ] I'll throw
out a bunch of stuff but I want to hear
from other people I'm very inspired even
the meeting I just had with Marc Ecko
and guys right like they're obviously a
media company and it had a lot to do
with the stuff that is your world line
but in general I guess the punch line
being I want to be aggressively on the
offense with this group like I think
we're thinking we've been spending the
first quarter this year on the defense
which i think is right and I'm happy
with the outcomes and I can taste the
permission of the Vayner name deployed
in areas to really work so that's
running through my mind that's always
been on my mind like could be interested
so just as you're living life like where
you see your attention go like people
have done that right and then you got to
think about how you make the business
feel right like where's this like
there's two things that are interesting
you make one big deal with one big
conglomerate that's big and stupid or
you have to go and quietly do what Walt
Disney did with Orlando right you lock
up you think it's this there's 47 big
people that have that and you go and buy
the rights from them consolidating
five-year deals give it like in
perpetuity like it was just to level it
up to business as you're thinking this
is good let's Tyler know
understanding what's going to happen
over the next 24 to 36 months in
reaction to something that happened is
the key to your strategy just like this
cool let's see what that clip looks like
I'll play with it a little bit that's a
great example first of all it's also
taking the IP and putting into a
different place
should have been an iPad an iPad and
iPhone gaming business 36 months ago if
I walked in 36 months ago not playing
Monday Morning Quarterback I would have
lose the IP into the world where I know
the kids are and then that would have
been the arbitrage back into the
physical location there's just a massive
misunderstanding of what to do without
[Music]
my beautiful [ __ ] know I can go find it
as I go
maybe it's the lab maybe it's the prime
idea for why you cry happy why you're
not i'ma tell you these momma crap I
care about you know lack of politics I
care about managing up down left right
yes I care about really understanding
the difference between traditional
creative and our version of it yeah in a
world worth changes constantly make sure
you're good at the craft I'm very simple
if I care about Facebook commercials
that are two minutes and I've seen from
beef or like if I like this or if I like
like the book that's what I want to make
the Alexa voice stuff that influencers
that now we're gonna have this big
creative off site yeah so you think that
will be like eight hours of like this so
I think that part of it the craft will
be very clear for you and the whole kind
of leadership of creative so I think
besides that it's very simple game here
be in a place where you don't feel any
insecurity and when you do use me in
Clawd and everything
using the the album is out or not out
there great so we can list we can link
it in this video we're about there
perfect and is there anything you want
to link to the full album or anything
sort of tour like anything okay you have
a page for that yes on my website
I'll pull it up yeah hard to carry you
celebrated his daughter's first birthday
yeah Congrats so the other good see your
kids on Instagram all day you're
hardcore Instagram yeah you are I mean I
see it I feel like I feel like I see
them more now than when I lived in the
same [ __ ] building of them that is so
real a hundred percent
musically yeah everybody is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 250 of
the askgaryvee show super excited 250
nice round number makes sense to have
superstar John Legend in the house
d-roc you're excited very excited thanks
for making this happen jump or pleasure
man you need to put out music man the
big advantage now of distribution online
is you need at bats don't fall in love
with that song you may love it the world
might may hate it you need to put out
ludecke you need to put out music right
now many people love it it'll start to
generate some buzz like people will
listen to a go to share it with their
friends and you start what if I don't
have views what if I don't have the
money to put out music as often as I
would like to like quality fountain then
then then you're stuck and you lost like
everybody else you need to figure it out
like Prince was a janitor in his studio
and the quality down yeah like that
money should not be a problem jahmai
listen man I miss you guys I love you
and I'm trying to be kind because John's
here everything you're saying is
backwards you need to do and work you're
coming up with all the wrong angles in
my opinion and I'm so pumped you called
because I'm hoping that this is the
break for the moment like you need to
come so far I heard it's the audience's
fault it's too far to the left the
music's too expensive you're fully fully
in excuse mode
you can put out plenty of quality music
John's point it's inexpensive and if you
want it so bad go [ __ ] work at the
studio in exchange for studio time like
you need to go out and put out music put
in the work put your head down and then
figure it out after that you need to put
out a hundred fifty [ __ ] songs and
see how people react to it before we
hear another phone call from you yeah
yeah you keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them
got it thank you you're welcome nicely
do good letters cool are we shaking no
smell the numbers okay what I do now
five is my favorite number love it man
thank yourself you know architect and a
Mason the fact that you it comes natural
to you to buy into the architecture
that's the part that holds everybody
back they don't fully believe me they
don't believe me that they should eat
[ __ ] from 23 to 31 they don't believe
that a31 you feel like a kid they don't
believe like save your money and don't
do [ __ ] like [ __ ] grind and like work
18 hours of it they don't believe that
be the bigger person somebody upsets you
like eat it like they don't believe that
so if you believe that when you're
[ __ ] halfway home and now the only
other part is like do you actually know
the [ __ ] you're talking about
like how many brands do you follow on
Facebook do you read a day of duty
TechCrunch you talk do you look like
soon in the game you know the X's and
O's like you know how to coach the kids
but you actually know the X's and O's
that's over my first real job was
working as a doorman
and there I learned opening up doors to
people of a number or name so I placed
one name lesser than my parents however
you of 18 so I think the one thing that
other peeps that have gray hairs and
start losing their hair will tell you is
like just make sure you're mentally
prepared for the foundation of the
ground to be shaky because I think
you've got it
you know least from what I heard in the
reason I'm getting you that advice and I
think you've got stuff figured out other
than when the football field turns into
a hockey arena that's right and that
experience is real tricky especially if
you're overextended and not sitting out
enough liquid and like I even even
invest in anything in a year do it real
pleasure man good work
[Music]
never
you come with or no Hey
sure nobody's man a bit boring for I'll
do that
the shadowboxing thing please make a
commitment to every trend that you think
is coming because that is how you win
like consistently like like even my dick
[ __ ]
I write four articles a year I win for
everything like as soon as I know
musically is going to matter I write for
musically marketing things and I win
every time so the one thing you have to
think about is can you predict flash
really move very quickly on very small
what micro trends in your demo like
sweet pea masks like if you think sweet
peas are going to be smashed up and be
face masks like nine a year from now you
have to jump as quickly as possible in
those because that is actually winning
that is absolutely winning like in the
world work so like the one thing I know
from all the media companies like
founders and people I talked to is the
what where they all have the best ninjas
they can have in all fighting the one
thing is who's the first person that was
right that Clif bars were going to be
big or [ __ ] you know raccoon eyes or
[ __ ] like shadow boxing so that's an
editorial like a unique basically right
[ __ ] before it actually happened or
literally create the [ __ ] trend good
piece of content that goes on up there
it goes to like 161
the best eye thing I've seen is around
30 but darling
we need more written piece of content
and we need to get a writer talk to Andy
about that
[Music]
the way that I was told to the heated
I can help remember
I said I loved you like never let it
work
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you standing back there
and listening to the utter love that is
coming out of this room and and the mic
and the ridiculousness that's going on
over there I'm really excited I stopped
by so congrats my man I appreciate that
you love the hustle as much as I do I'm
humbled that you share my [ __ ] I love
the guys love this man so much I'm super
pumped I stopped by for a kiss we're
doing the tears I was born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union so this is how
we do it this means to good health
nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
live in a weird life yeah yeah I mean
like once in a while [ __ ] just hit me
and I want to do supper fast I was
really glad we did that
[Music]
what a feel and I should say uh nothing
you know cushion Islands without a yeah
the video where he's explaining it that
we can chop down is incredible go into a
different place which is we have to know
our craft like it's important for
everybody here to be deeply curious
weebly skilled and deeply passionate
about Facebook commercials about
influencer marketing about Alexa voice
you need to follow what I'm putting out
to the world and as a company we need to
do better job as in Oregon I need to do
a better job but like one of the things
is like there's no I'm not hiding from
this I'm putting it out like it's there
every day it's in the water and so I
think whether that's your the kind of
learner that okay you'll just go and
just like read about Alexa boy stuff or
watch videos or if you need anything for
me or the center I think it's super
important that you're focused on the
things that the organization is focused
about and I don't think it takes that
much effort to know one of the things
that I hear a lot from people is like we
need this we need this and I'm like you
know it's one thing of a kid says that
but like anybody at this table like if
you're not capable of reaching out or
doing a little homework or paying
attention feelings you can't play at
this level oh I think it's super
important that if the world is that a
and what I just described as V and I
Gary I met like R and T I need you guys
to move away from B and C because that's
where we are as a collective as leaders
well thank you
yeah
we go
10:39 go my next meeting
obviously sure just saw great a great
meeting with commuters at vaynermedia
felt good cool tone right mellow in like
tight like but like it was like chill it
was very productively there was like
Monica calm confidence yeah yeah calm
calm
gotta get that calm confidence kids all
right one more meeting get home
public close to midnight tonight early
day tomorrow so I solid grinding
executing operating day spent really
unusual I've been home like like a month
so unheard of for me a lot of
serendipity bunch of canceled West Coast
trips and stuff of that nature so it's
been interesting um productive
going in for my meeting today
from the trash
like a lot of people's strategies
goodnight close the perfect
[Music]
I need a kid a man - I need to stop my
thing